foreign
good day everyone welcome and happy St Patrick's
Day I'm Jack Van Horn from the University of
Virginia and I am very proud to welcome you
to this edition of our 2022-2023 foundations
of biomedical data science seminar Series this
lecture series is supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of Virginia the UVA
brain Institute the College of Arts and Sciences
the school of data science and through a grant
from the National Institutes of General Medical
Sciences since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has focused on the
use of data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and statistical
modeling as they pertain to different themes
in the biomedical and Health Sciences this
year's theme is data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic where each
week we enjoy presentations from leading thinkers
about the issues the promise opportunities and
hurdles associated with understanding the
secondary health effects of covid-19 these
Inc include but are not limited to delayed Health
checkups and treatments mental health drug abuse
increased obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS covid-19 virus
participants selected for our biomedical data
science Innovation lab program will leverage
these presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person Grant project development
Workshop to be held at the lodge at St Edwards
Park in beautiful Seattle Washington in June of
2023. today I am delighted to welcome our speaker
Dr Katherine Kim from the miter Corporation Dr Kim
is a health informatics researcher and expert
in digital health and Community engagement she
received her PhD from UC Davis and a masters
in public health and a masters of Business
Administration from UC Berkeley and her ba from
Harvard University she is a principal of consumer
health informatics at the miter corporation
which is a non-profit organization working
with government and private sectors to improve
the safety stability and the well-being of our
nation she is also an adject associate professor
at the University of California Davis in their
school of medicine and Public Health Sciences
department at miter Dr Kim currently leads the
activate Group which is a comprehensive model
for Equitable and sustainable digital health for
underserved and Rural communities the activate
program provides technology and assistance to
develop virtual care remote patient monitoring and
digital health literacy which engages patients and
improves Health outcomes she also serves as
the clinical lead for miter's age better lab
which is a connector and collaborator with
Academia government and Industry for aging
research and digital Health Solutions she is
a fellow of the American medical informatics
Association chair of the consumer health
informatics working group and she's received
received numerous awards for her community
engagement and her participatory research
related to technology and health in continuing
with today's 2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar series theme today's lecture is entitled
digitalhealth Equity Dr Kim will discuss the
digital Health Equity including a framework
for community co-production of digital Health
Equity interventions that focused on policies and
other things which interact in a local context
amongst the stakeholders to deliver outcomes of
digital Health Equity she will also share the
activate project a demonstration of community
co-production on a platform for remote patient
monitoring chronic illness management and as
always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via YouTube If you are watching
on YouTube thank you so much for joining us also
our specially selected 2022-2023 biomedical
data science Innovation lab participants and
alumni are encouraged to submit any questions
they have via the zoom chat sessions I will
synthesize these questions and I will ask them
on your behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that welcome Kathy
we are so excited to hear from you today
thank you very much I am really pleased to be here
um with all of you to talk about this topic which
is near and dear to my heart to digital Health
Equity so let's start with some definitions
um what is digital Equity well digital Equity is
the information technology capacity of individuals
and communities to fully participate in this in
society and the economy um uh access to broadband
connectivity is a key component of digital
equity and that's achieved when people and
communities are all able to access and use
affordable high-speed and reliable internet
that meets their long-term needs there are a
number of barriers to digital equity for all um
all communities and they include policies from the
federal to the local level practices by technology
and internet companies infrastructure barriers due
to the geography or the built environment as well
as digital redlining which is the intentional lack
of investment in infrastructure and Affordable
Services for low-income and minority communities
so it's important to start with digital Equity
um because there's a real National investment
happening right now to address these barriers
this is funding that came through last year
administered by the national telecommunications
Information Administration that's called
the Broadband for all our internet for all
um and this funding has started to flow
to really address the middle mile to Last
Mile connection so middle mile is really
that that Regional level of infrastructure
um primarily to States and regions to make sure
that um there's there's Broadband availability
and then the last mile is going from that
Regional infrastructure to the individuals
neighborhoods and Community Based organizations so
they can actually access what is available to them
so this ntia funding is really in there
are multiple programs that are being funded
um that again are being um the the dollars are
going to the States but a really key component of
this program is to address digital equity and so
there are specific requirements um that come with
this funding to make sure that there are plans um
so that the communities and the individuals who
do not have access currently um are taken care
so that they have access to this infrastructure
um so this is a really important National topic
right now but now let's talk about digital Health
Equity um so digital Health Equity obviously
depends on connectivity and many people will
say that uh Broadband connectivity is a social
determinive health that access to the internet
is has become a critical component of people's
ability to access health and health care so the
definition of digital Health Equity is access
to digital Healthcare appropriate design of
solutions and the benefits and outcomes of
digital Health experiences so it's not just
access to digital tools but it's actually making
sure that those Solutions the interventions the
programs that we create are appropriate
and accessible to all of our communities
so um there are several
Frameworks that have been proposed
um for thinking about digital Health Equity um
one of those Frameworks would give these sort of
Five drivers that are important to pay attention
to um similar to what you saw in digital Equity it
also includes the policy instructional drivers
it includes system level influences like the
public health and the healthcare settings
in our community it includes community
and social factors such as the role of family
and friends and community-based organizations
and of course there are individual influences such
as an individual skills digital literacy health
literacy and their motivation to use um these
available digital Health Solutions and then there
are characteristics of the platforms themselves
such as are they usable are they accessible so you
can see how this these concepts are really large
they're big scale Concepts right these are not
um things that you can address sort of in a
silo they really require lots of collaboration
across multiple um disciplines and multiple
multiple sectors of our um of our community
the other definition that I wanted to share
is what is the digital Health ecosystem you
know there's so many terms that we use to refer to
these things sometimes it's Telehealth sometimes
it's telemedicine um you know it's it's really the
the broad ecosystem that supports connected health
um so course connectivity is essential but it
may include systems that you're familiar with
like Telehealth um telemedicine but
it may be technologies that are used
um in you know in the the delivery of very
complicated um uh uh services like remotely guided
surgery it includes real-time patient monitoring
and that may include for acute services like
hospital at home and intensive care monitoring but
it may also be for things that are more managed
by individuals so self-care self-management for
things like chronic illnesses it also includes
the Technologies themselves that people use so
data collection from sensors that are either
in the environment in the ambient environment or
that are worn by individuals and then it includes
some really important infrastructural components
like data exchange across devices and platforms
which you can see just from those items that
are in the list above much of the data that
is in each of these systems is not necessarily
shared with other systems or with the patients
themselves and often cannot be aggregated in
ways that make it easy to compute or to analyze
um it also includes the ability of people
to access health information and treatment
information um so can people get the information
when they need it or can it be delivered in ways
that um that are accessible and offered at
a time um when when it's most beneficial
we also need to be thinking about accessibility
um for um of course our diverse population has
diverse capabilities and capacities to
interact with technology so we need to be
thinking about all the ways that we might
interact with technology including things
like voice mobility issues um other
assistive features and capabilities
um and then things like virtual
and augmented reality to make
um both treatment and health information health
education more accessible and interactive and
consumable by different types of people and then
Financial Technologies we know that Financial
Health or financial stability and security are
very tightly linked with with health status
so this is not necessarily a comprehensive
inventory but it just shows you the breadth
of Technologies and systems that are part
of that digital Health ecosystem foreign
so I'm going to tell you a little bit
about this project called activate
which is a community co-designed
digital Health Equity innovation
so activate is a project that was started as a
partnership of University of California Berkeley
and miter that really started in 2020 when it
was becoming clear that large Health Systems
academic medical centers Urban Health Systems
were very rapidly able to Pivot to Telehealth
and virtual care virtual visits when covid-19
really was gaining a foothold in the United States
um within weeks when I I was at UC Davis
health So within weeks we were able to
um get have you know thousands of patient
visits via Telehealth this was not the case
in underserved communities and particularly in
community health centers um in rural areas and
in in regions where they are the primary source
of Health Care and so we were very concerned
um that that these community health centers were
going to be left behind and they would not be able
to continue providing services to the residents
that were really dependent on them for care
um and so we were fortunate to receive an
anonymous donation and to to put up the system our
vision was to create an equitable digital Health
platform for Rural and underserved communities to
put the tools for health and well-being into the
hands of the person and their health care team
and the way that we saw ourselves completing that
or contributing to that Vision was to co-design
and Implement digital Health Solutions to really
take the advantages of these new technologies and
and bring them to the community but also to remove
the barriers to impactful use so our goals in
this program were to demonstrate this activate
platform in in um in three Health Centers we
actually completed four community health centers
that are using the system now um and that was done
in 2021 and 2022. and then to disseminate that
model across the state and the and the nation
um and create a roadmap to sustainability
and that's what we're working on this year
so as I mentioned um we were co-designing
this program with community and so our we
used a participatory design framework which
really relies on um the the principles that
um anything that you uh create for people um
has to really be um in intensively involved with
them both at the very beginning in defining the
problem defining the challenge and understanding
um how those people live and work and then
you need to embed with them throughout the
entire process so from design to testing to
implementation to evaluation and Beyond and
so that's what we did we worked with the health
center staff including providers nurses medical
assistants health coaches community health
workers and Outreach staff and we work with
patients of the health center with their
family members and caregivers and other
community members who were not receiving Care
at that Health Center in all we worked with
about 25 individuals on our co-design team
over the course of six months to produce this
as I mentioned we were really um trying
to bring the access to technology but also
recognizing that there are a lot of barriers
to adopting digital Health Solutions for both
the community clinics as well as the individuals
um the health centers that we work with are in
communities that are rural that treat primarily uh
treat a large proportion of agricultural workers
um and so we needed to make sure that we're
addressing all the barriers because if you have
a solution um and and people are faced with many
barriers to using your solution any one of those
barriers can put can you know stop the program
from being successful so we need to take a very
comprehensive approach um to addressing all the
barriers that we thought might get in the way
so some of those barriers include things
like having a digital health program that
is adapted to the culture in the setting um so
many of our evidence-based programs like chronic
Care Management disease management programs were
studied and developed in academic medical centers
often in settings that have more resources um you
know and in research projects so lots of things
provided for you but if you were to try and do
those kinds of programs in a small community
health center that doesn't have the resources
it may not be as effective as what you saw in
research so you need to really adapt what you do
to the right to to the level that is appropriate
and and acceptable to the culture and the setting
in which you're working a second barrier for the
clinic is Technology Solutions that will really
work um they have to be optimized for how the
clinic works the work the clinical workflows the
staff and the level of experience that they have
um and they have to um really be attendant to the
infrastructure that's in the clinic for example
this next one is complete and interoperable data
well if you have an electronic health record
system and you're trying to add remote patient
monitoring or you're trying to do Telehealth
visits or you're trying to bring in other kinds of
Technology if that doesn't interoperate with your
electronic health record if the data doesn't even
go into your electronic health record it causes
um you know problems in terms of the workflow
in the clinic on the availability of the data
to the providers when they're offering the
care and it limits the ability to analyze
that data later to know whether you have a
effective efficacious or effective program
um complete and interrupt over data it is a real
a really critical uh barrier because we see many
of the solutions that are implemented in the
health systems although they could be integrated
they often are not because there's an additional
expense or there's just additional resources that
need to sort of keep those interfaces running
um the next barrier is the availability of of
time and the experience with digital programs for
the clinic staff and providers many of them may
be individually technology Savvy may be using
you know technology for personal use but they
may have had no experience in creating
a digital health program that works in
in their health center and the clinics are very
understaffed um you know in kova they were even
more understaffed than on the right on a normal
basis and so just having time to think about how
they would create a program or having time to
implement that program was really constrained
um and then let's move to some individual barriers
many individuals in rural areas who are low income
who are um uh who may not speak English as a first
language are also the ones that um don't have
up-to-date Computing devices smartphones tablets
laptops or who don't have a connectivity um so um
you know they they have both Health disparities
and they have digital disparities so we find that
many individuals that are being served by these
Health Centers will tell you they have smartphone
um but when you ask can they use that to download
a recent app they they can't because they didn't
have enough data in their data prepaid data plans
or the smartphone is an older version and hasn't
been upgraded and so actually cannot um cannot use
Uh current apps so access to up-to-date Computing
devices and Technology uh sorry and internet
access is a real concern another in in our
program was a disparity around access to remote
patient monitoring devices which I will tell you
about in in a little bit but most health plans
do not cover remote monitoring devices so things
like bukometers connected glucometers connected
um uh um uh blood pressure machines other kinds
of things that that you know people may need to
have on a daily basis to to manage their condition
um individual digital health literacy
so many of these participants in rural
communities if they haven't had access to
these kinds of Technologies in the past
um don't have experience and so they're not sure
how to pair devices how do you how do you use
Bluetooth how do you know whether you're you're
um you know your internet is actually working how
do you you know connect things so their ability to
have both the digital skills and the health skills
combined may be a barrier and then finally stable
and sustainable funding many people didn't realize
that prior to covid-19 community health centers
were not reimbursed for for Telehealth they were
actually not allowed to provide Telehealth to
patients in their own homes they could be a
clinical site and connect to a specialist for
a specialty consult with the patient in you
know in their in the clinic room but they were not
allowed to provide the Telehealth service directly
to the patient so it's only because of the public
health emergency that allowed clinics to do to do
Telehealth and to be reimbursed in for it and so
there was no funding store since no resources for
um for health centers to do this um now
that we all have experience in doing
Telehealth many of the health centers
are able to to do it and do it well
um you know the hope is that there
will be funding sources that continue
um so that we can continue with the progress
that was made during the during the pandemic
so understanding that we were trying to co-design
a platform um to allow for digital Health in this
community health centers and address all of these
barriers this is what we created so this is just
a very simple rendering graphic about what we
did this is a platform that is HIPAA compliant
so it does um it you know it does uh provide for
both privacy and security but it is flexible as
well and it was important that this is flexible
because as a research and code design project
it was not an attempt to create a commercially
available system that would replace what clinics
were doing but rather to be an adjunct to
be complementary to the Technologies they
had to provide additional capabilities and to make
sure that all of their technology worked together
so that it could be streamlined and efficient
so um the platform integrates remote patient
monitoring devices those devices were selected by
each Health Center for what they were hoping to
use what they had experience using and in the
cases where there was insurance coverage like
under Medicare devices that would be actually
covered by insurance if that was an option
so we have seven devices that we
have integrated that are in use
um we provided a pairing app so that um uh
participants who had these devices could
download this app um be able to automatically pair
the devices with our system that would identify
the patient and identify the device and so that
data could be brought together in our servers and
matched to medical records so all that data
goes into electronic health records systems
and the workflows are are streamlined and
integrated so that it can work alongside with
the virtual visit system if the health center has
that as well as other devices if their preferences
for the health center for how they want to run
this system um and finally their interfaces um
user interfaces for the program manager as well as
the participants so they can see their data so the
the program manager can run um you know analyzes
and to see the status of all of the patients that
are are participating in their program and then
there's some analytics um and um and ways for
people to to see um as a group how how the the
patients are doing and what the outcomes are
um so this system is used by participants
themselves these are all participants
in in the first phase of this where all
participants with diabetes and hypertension
um and then the teamlets in the health center
and the teamlets are um the healthcare provider
um the medical assistants health coaches and
community health workers if they have them one
of the really important things here is that the
teamlet needs to really work together and it was
a model that not all Health Centers use but it was
important that they work together because this is
a technology adopt in part a technology adoption
program and so it needs to be adopted by the staff
at the clinic and it needs to be adopted by the
participants and so you really have to address
all of that infrastructure and all the barriers
that we talked about previously and you have to
have people on the teamlet who can make sure that
that all of those things are being taken care of
the other important um development here is
something we call the digital Health pathway and
this is the operating model for person-centered
self-management and care coordination
this is a way of modeling all of the touch points
between the clinic and a participant and we
created this for each condition it's customized
by condition as well as adjusted for each Clinic
um and as I said it Maps every touch
point and the importance of that is
to one make sure that we understand the
clinical workflow the operational workflow
um the the how the Technologies should
interoperate so that that's all mapped
out as part of the planning process and
procedures are created so that once you
implement the program it works for everyone in the
clinic and it works for each of the participants
um the other important Concept in the digital
Health pathway is that with all these touch
points you um you really proactively think about
um how you can have each action be digital first
um and that means that there is a um a capability
within the technology to handle it in an automated
way or in a in um that the technology has the
capacity to do that but it's not digital only
and that's important because if you're going to
be person centered you need to recognize that
not everybody has the same appetite or interest to
use technology for every touch Point people still
want a personal relationship with their health
care provider and so they may not always want
a virtual visit they may want to have you know an
in-person visit with their provider they may also
want to use the telephone at certain times and
not do a a video call or there may be times when
um you know they they really want education from
a health coach and not to to read um or view you
know something online so you have all these touch
points that are digital first mean there's a
capability for it to be done using the platform
but that's not the only way people can interact
and then finally it's combining the right touch
with the right Tech so that you really tailor
the support and the technology to the touch point
and to the purpose or the goal that you're trying
to accomplish so this is a model that helps you
to understand that and helps you to to build for
that to design for that and implement it so we do
have outcomes um we have a paper that's currently
in review for the outcomes so I'm not going to
share the outcomes here but we will say that it
has achieved very substantial improvements um
for hemoglobin A1C for those with diabetes and
blood pressure for those with hypertension in
these Health Centers so it is fully implemented
um and we have two health centers that have
a substantial number of patients so it's in
use with several hundreds of patients in two and
then two additional health centers that are just
online now and and starting their enrollment
of patients so we've had very good outcomes
so now I want to talk a little bit about the data
science implications of digital Health Solutions
like activate and this is research that we are
are currently undertaking um uh we started this
this research project last year and it's called
the community connectivity framework for digital
Health Equity and this is a a research project to
really understand um uh how do you in how do you
develop and Implement digital health programs that
will achieve Health Equity outcomes um and there's
not a lot of evidence um actually about how you
create those programs or even what the outcomes um
are that you should be measuring to know whether
digital Health um uh improves or um impacts equity
um so there are some Frameworks um one of which I
shared with you in at the beginning of this talk
but there's not a lot of evidence um the second
thing is the Frameworks that that are available
are not focused so much on implementation
their focused on sort of make sure um that
uh that we can conduct research right they're
explanatory models or explanatory Frameworks
so this was intended to be a very pragmatic
framework that helps Community organizations
um and particularly underserved communities
understand how to develop interventions in
ways that are evidence-based and
that in ways that you can assure
that they're going to accomplish uh the
equity outcomes that you're hoping for
um and so there are um some some really key
components here one is that digital Health the
digital Health Equity relies both on the supply
and demand right these are economic Concepts where
the supply of um uh not only connectivity
but digital Health Services needs to be
um needs to be there um and when you talk about
underserved communities um I you know shared in
those barriers that we don't have adequate
Supply actually on either of those things
um there also needs to be Demand on the the
part of the communities themselves so that's
knowledge of the available Solutions and the
driver of motivation to use them from both the
individuals and community-based organizations in
delivering digital Health Equity Solutions um you
you know we also chatted about how multi-sectoral
you know collaboration needs to be a component of
planning these kinds of things because there's a
whole ecosystem underlying the delivery of digital
Health Equity and so Partnerships are really
crucial um to these kinds of interventions
um the the creation of these programs
implementation and achieving outcomes also depends
on the local environment so what um what policies
are impacting you not just at the federal or state
level but at the local level um what is the local
environment like for Innovation for partnership
um for delivery of Technology um and so there's
this whole backdrop of the local context that
also needs to be taken into account and so
it's a complex set of forces and interactions
that need to occur to create a successful
intervention and activate was an example of this
um it was an example of increasing
the supply it was an example of
um uh increasing demand it was partnership among a
university a private you know non-profit research
and development organization with community health
centers and members of the community to create
a solution to deliver that solution and then
within the the context of covid-19 where there
was a recognition that we needed Telehealth and
digital Health Solutions in the in the community
health centers and policy changes such as the
public health emergency waivers that allowed
us to actually Implement such a solution so it's
an example that illustrates how you need to take
into account all of these um these Concepts
when you're creating a solution so in that in
with the backdrop of all that complexity though
um uh what you know how how could you actually
um sort of take advantage of data science so
um there there's um a wealth of real world data
um in uh you know we have clinical data
from electronic health records we have
remote monitoring data more frequent you know
more frequently now than has been in the past
um but in projects like activate and others we
have person reported observations these might
be things like um you know text messaging or um
you know individual tracking um self-tracking
applications you know those kinds of data sets
that are now becoming more common we also have
environment and climate data right that we know
has a great effect on on health and particularly
chronic conditions um so what's the weather what
is the level of air pollution and water pollution
um you know hottest temperature and heat
um uh or or natural disasters affect
people's Health at particular times um we
also have social determinants of Health
um and I will point you um specifically
to this citation at the bottom that's the
um from the assistant Secretary of planning and
evaluation for Health and Human Services this is
a review that is is maybe a particular interest to
this year's data science Innovation lab it was a
scoping review that we conducted and published
on data elements for research on the role of
social determinants of Health in coronavirus
2019 infection and outcomes in the U.S this
report shares you know uh from the research the
kinds of data sources that that researchers were
able to take advantage of including things like
clinical data remote monitoring person report
observations environmental data but also social
determinants data not just at the individual
level but at the population level data that
comes from census data that comes from National
um you know cohort surveys data that comes from
indices that are calculated um population level
measures about social determinants in in States in
regions um or even down to the neighborhood level
um so these population level data sets are
also important uh sources of real world data
um but also the business and policy environment
right we have lots of data about that come from
the commercial sector and being able to access
those data would are would be very important to
help as well as policy particularly with um
the internet for all the federal initiative
and the ntia funding lots of data is is
being currently collected at both federal
and state levels about connectivity about
Broadband speeds about barriers to access
um and um and making that data available for
analysis is an important aspect of the program
so when you think about all those different
sources of real world data that might help
you to ask questions and I just offer you know a
couple of relevant health research questions that
um the the health centers um that Health
researchers might be interested in um related
to the kinds of um data that we have inactivate so
for example what are the factors that contribute
to a health condition or outcome using not just
what was created in the data sources that were
created and activate but also these other real
world environmental and Commercial data sources
um Are there natural groupings of participants and
can we use those groupings to learn uh more about
triggers that precede a particular condition or
outcome as I mentioned we know we we hypothesize
that in um weather conditions do impact um you
know people with cardiac conditions people with
um uh pulmonary conditions respiratory conditions
but also the interactions of those kinds of things
also affect diabetes and other conditions so
what are the natural groupings of participants
um with their clinical and individual
characteristics interacting with the environment
that would help us to understand whether they have
a condition um what the um what the particular
outcomes might be for them or what might trigger a
worsening or Improvement of a condition or outcome
and then can we predict the next episode
when the next episode is likely to happen
so um these are you know questions that you might
consider as you think about your own research
um and the data sources that
you have available to you
um but um what I'm asking here is to think
about what is relevant to your community to
your providers and to the populations that
you're hoping to impact with your research
so as you consider all these different data
sources again as you can tell I always come
back to ecosystem um that there this is really an
ecosystem for digital Health it's an ecosystem of
Health for our communities and and for um people
who are developing um Technologies or trying to
analyze um the information the data that we get
from them um this is a Continuum of the right
technology and the Right Touch as I mentioned
before we thought about this concept as in the
development of activate there are things in
healthcare that that require Personal Touch
um and may require um in person or at least um
trusted relationships to do things like setting
personal and clinical goals things like addressing
barriers to digital and health self-efficacy
um you know uh things like shared decision
making among patients and providers provision of
medical interventions and and procedures and then
addressing um other kinds of barriers to care that
may require more Personal Touch um but there's
lots of technologies that we can take advantage of
some of the data collection technologies that
we've already talked about like in in sensors but
medical devices as well um and then interoperable
and computable data right making sure that that
data from Real World sources can be used can
be developed in ways to make it computable and
interoperable for use by the Healthcare System and
a different computation and analytic techniques
um as we think about you know machine learning
and artificial intelligence we need to also
be thinking about uh fairness and bias in
our algorithms um assurance that AI is is
um uh providing appropriate um uh uh
Direction and will be used appropriately
um and then you know other kinds of sort of
ethical um ethical moral and legal issues
Insight Generation Um uh again thinking about
decision support thinking about applying what we
learned from our algorithms um into the practice
of of self-management of improving your health
and of the provision of Health Care um thinking
about the policy lovers um again federal state
and local levels and then making sure that um self
that individuals can use all of the technology and
um the the knowledge that comes
out of technology to apply it
to their own personal situations to do
self-management to do care coordination
so it's a balance of the right technology and
the Right Touch it's not um just you know you are
either high tech or high touch you really can be
both but as long as they're balanced in the right
proportions as you go through interacting
with individuals and communities foreign
so I I will stop there um and be open to questions
but I hope that um this this talk has has brought
some information to you about why digital Health
Equity is important um and relevant um to those
of you in in data science um and uh brought you
some some things to think about as you proceed
in your own research um using data science to
improve um health and health care and I will um
just let you know that there are references to
all the citations that I provided in this talk
Kathy thank you so much and I want to uh just
invite any of our participants here that are
watching on Zoom to send in any questions
they may have via the chat feature and
um I'll take a look at those and ask them on your
behalf uh with with Kathy Kathy one of the things
which I I want to kind of start at the end of
your presentation that you talked about which
I think is kind of important especially in the
context of kind of how we often think of as data
Sciences trying to remove the human from the
loop many times and I liked how you brought in
the notion of a personal touch um where the human
is firmly in the loop and um what can you share
with us any like stories of that as a successful
strategy that's uh you know has been born out of
this model that you've described absolutely um
I'll give two examples um and that's a wonderful
question thank you for asking that um Jack um so
I'll give you one example from our design process
um and that is that we had you know patients and
family members who were in our co-designer team
and one of those participants
gave us told us a story
um she said that you know she has um uh high
blood pressure among other things and her doctor
had told her go get a blood pressure machine you
could just go buy it you know at the drugstore
and you need to be measuring your um your blood
pressure every day and taking care of yourself
right and then let me know you know what your
readings are and how it's going so she was doing
what she thought they told her to do she went
to the drugstore she bought a device she was
measuring it every day um and when she went to
talk to the doctor she said well how's it going
um and you know how are my readings and
the doctor said I don't have your readings
she thought that it was automatically somehow
going to the doctor and you know she didn't
she didn't know that she had to buy a particular
kind that allowed her to connect through Bluetooth
and set it up like no one had explained that
to her and then it turned out that her blood
pressures had not improved and she's like well
I you know I was watching the numbers but she
didn't really know what the numbers meant and
she was making some assumptions about them but
no one had sat her down and said well this is
what they mean and what you should do about it
when you see these readings so all of these kind
of points of of failure for her led to her feeling
ashamed you know that she had done something that
was you know she felt ignorant she felt like you
know and she'd wasted all this time so it led
to her feeling badly fortunately she's the type
of person who didn't let that stop her and she
said I'm going to be involved in this project
because I want you to learn from my experience
right what not to do for the next patient
so it's that Personal Touch that no one had asked
her what she needed to know no one had said what
might get in your way no one had checked in with
her about how it was going um there were just a
lot of assumptions made so that personal touch
someone just talking to her would may have you
know uh sort of interrupted that cycle um early
on to make sure that it was going to be useful
for her and for for the doctor I I think that that
usability thing is so important I mean we sort of
assumed that people are I don't know that they're
they're just aware enough these days right oh yeah
just go to the store and buy the device and it
it will just magically present itself about how
you're supposed to deploy it right and for some
folks that may be more difficult than others and
we shouldn't make those assumptions absolutely
um the other example that I would give is a I
think a very simple example which is now we have
hundreds of patients taking their blood pressure
as many many times and taking glucometer readings
many times and I'm sure people have said well what
is the doctor supposed to do with thousands
of readings right we have 10 000 measures now
what's the doctor supposed to do with all of that
right what I mean how you know they're not going
to look at every one of these readings so how do
we make that something that's useful clinically
um so one of the things that we did was
to be able to graph that information
to set um to implement threshold levels that the
health center um determined were ones that you
know they wanted to have information about about
people and to provide um patterns and trends um
because what a clinician will tell you is that
this an individual may have on on average you
know a higher blood pressure and so trying
to get them to some arbitrary standard blood
pressure may not actually be the right decision
right but if you don't know what their what their
um their Baseline normal blood pressure is
you may just be kind of beating up on them
get it down get it down but you might not realize
that in fact they have gotten it down right so
um being able to provide that information
um in a in a way that is personalized to
the individual's particular health status and can
show a provider what those Trends are um on a you
know daily weekly monthly basis is what makes that
information useful and so those are the kinds of
um you know data visualizations that we are able
to provide and now in that activate um you know
program manager the provider with the health coach
and the uh the nurse can actually look at all the
patients and at a glance understand um what those
measures mean and can make decisions then with the
patient based on on those kinds of Trends so there
again the the um importance of understanding the
real problem for the clinics staff and providers
was critical to designing a solution that was
going to work for them and that that came
from being embedded and designing with them
foreign Kathy you talked about like the you know
folks that you're focused on in rural communities
um you know and sort of this topic of familiarity
with technology kind of is gonna vary widely
right if you're in a big urban area you're
probably seeing a lot of the technology if
you're in a rural area you know maybe you're not
as exposed to it um on the other hand there are
people working in those rural communities who not
only might they not have access to the technology
they might not understand it but they also may
have some reservations about using it and I'm
thinking about undocumented workers and they
may have some serious worries about utilizing
technology that might expose them as undocumented
is that this might be a sensitive topic but I'm
curious if you have any experience with this
or I mean from you know being in the part of
California you're in you might see this from time
to time I'm curious absolutely that's a really big
concern among particularly among agricultural
workers because many of them are undocumented
or have family members who are undocumented
and so providing information even going to
um you know a hospital um or you know in in the
case of covid coming to get a covered vaccine
there was a lot of cause for concern about what
information will I have to give what will they do
with that information will they ask me questions
that put me at risk for my family members at risk
um and so you know signing up for the affordable
connectivity program which is the federal you
know program to give every household access to the
internet a lot of people are are concerned about
doing that because they have to give information
to the government so this partnership at the
local level between Healthcare organizations
and Community organizations along with these
sort of state and federal programs is really
critical because it's the local community-based
organization that is the trusted entity to
those individual members of the community
so it's really important that
those trusted entities the the
um be involved in delivering the message and an
assisting individual people so that's part of this
community connectivity framework this is why you
have to have that partnership as part of Designing
the program and developing and implementing
the program you kind of introduced your talk